heute live diesmal am vormittag kurz vor
10 uhr herzlich willkommen schön dass
ihr dabei seid fast acht monate nach dem
prozessbeginn wird heute das
oberlandesgericht in frankfurt am main
das urteil im mordfall walter lübke
verkünden dem ehemaligen
regierungspräsidenten von kassel der
sich unter anderem für die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen stark gemacht hatte
sprecher später sprechen wir auch noch
mit andreas hollstein er wiederum ist
ehemaliger bürgermeister der stadt
altena im sauerland auch er wurde
körperlich angegriffen und weil er auch
er eine liberale flüchtlingspolitik
verfolgt hat das dann später im programm
seit juni also vergangenen jahres
verhandelt im verrückte das gericht
gegen den mutmaßlichen täter und gegen
einen wegen beihilfe mit angeklagten
die bundesanwaltschaft geht von einem
rechtsextremistischen motiv aus die
beiden beschuldigten waren zuvor viele
jahre in der rechtsextremen szene
unterwegs ford beobachtet den prozess
heute in mein kollege christian decker
und da sehen wir schon christian hallo
der prozess hat sich insgesamt bislang
über 44 verhandlungstage erstreckt und
man kann wohl schon auch sagen er hat
die eine oder andere überraschende
wendung parat gehabt
ja in der tat der prozess hat sich lange
hingezogen und es gab diverse vorfälle
die für überraschung gesorgt haben
zum beispiel hat der hauptangeklagte
stefan es hatte ja schon in der u haft
ein erstes geständnis abgelegt das er
dann widerrufen hat und zweites
geständnis abgelegt hat auch das war
noch während des ermittlungsverfahrens
in der ersten version hatte er gesagt er
sei alleine nachts auf der terrasse
gewesen und er habe den tödlichen schuss
abgegeben
in der zweiten version des geständnisses
sagte stefan ernst dann dass markus
harder mit angeklagte mit dabei gewesen
sei und dieser den schuss abgegeben habe
dann vor gericht präsentierte er eine
dritte version ein drittes geständnis in
dieser version sei der mitangeklagte
markus h auch mit dabei gewesen vor ort
aber der schuss sei von ihm also von
stefan ernst abgegeben worden
es gibt also drei verschiedene varianten
wie das geschehen in dieser nacht
abgelaufen sein könnte und das gericht
hat jetzt in dem heutigen urteil die
aufgabe zu bewerten welche dieser drei
varianten die glaubwürdigste ist und für
welche dieser varianten ist die die
meisten beweise und belege gibt
eine weitere sache die sich in dem
verfahren zugetragen hat ist das eine
der verteidiger von stefan ernst
entpflichtet wurde das heißt das gericht
hat das vertrauensverhältnis zwischen
stefan ernst und seinem verteidiger als
so zerrüttet angesehen dass das gericht
angeordnet hat dass dieser verteidiger
nicht mehr weiterhin der verteidiger von
stefan ernst sein darf
also dass auch ein ungewöhnlicher
vorgang ist vielleicht gerade noch mal
zu den verschiedenen geständnissen dies
gab das ist ja nun nicht gerade
vorteilhaft für die glaubwürdigkeit auch
von stefan ernst wie geht das gericht
mit sowas um dafür dass gerichts ist das
einigermaßen schwierig damit umzugehen
natürlich wenn drei verschiedene
varianten vom gleichen tatablauf
präsentiert werden und das gericht muss
im prinzip ja bewerten welche dieser
varianten die wahrscheinlichste ist
allerdings was man jetzt auch schon vor
verkündung des urteils sagen kann ist
dass das gericht stefan ernst nicht
unbedingt alles glaubt denn der mitte an
kontakte marcus h wurde im oktober aus
der untersuchungshaft entlassen
da das gericht gesagt hat ein dringender
tatverdacht dass er eben beihilfe zu
diesen zu dieser tat eben möglicherweise
zu diesem mord geleistet hat dieser
verdacht sei nicht mehr so dringend dass
die untersuchungshaft gerechtfertigt
sein und ein aspekt in der begründung
des gerichts war auch der dass stefan
ernst eben durch diese dreifach
geständnisse nicht mehr so glaubwürdig
auf das gericht wirke
daran kann man sehen dass das gericht
durchaus stefan ernst als nicht gerade
glaubwürdig einstufte
wir sprechen gleich weiter christian
aber wir haben dadurch schon ein paar
sachen angerissen die natürlich wichtig
sind auch für unsere user und zuschauer
im zusammenhang nochmal mit dem fall
mein kollege thomas garcia blickt noch
einmal auf das geschehen bis hierhin
zurück
walter lübcke kasseler
regierungspräsident es ist die nacht vom
ersten auf den 2 juni 2009 10 als er auf
seiner terrasse in wolfhagen erschossen
wird aus nächster nähe
kurz nach der trauerfeier die nachricht
es gibt eine dna-spur und einen treffer
in der datenbank am 16 juni die
festnahme stefan ernst ist ein
vorbestrafter neonazi aus kassel
zehn tage später legte er ein geständnis
ab er habe allein gehandelt
tatmotiv auf einer info veranstaltung
hatte lücke die flüchtlingspolitik der
bundesregierung verteidigt noch ein
möglicher täter wird festgenommen marcus
h er soll den kauf der tatwaffe
vermittelt haben
ein paar tage später stefan ernst
widerruft sein geständnis
knapp ein jahr später ist prozessauftakt
davor und danach präsentiert ernst
mehrere tatversionen er war nicht allein
sondern mit markus höcke der habe
versehentlich geschossen
in einem dritten geständnis korrigiert
ernst er selbst habe den tödlichen
schuss abgegeben
22 dezember 2020
die staatsanwaltschaft fordert für ernst
lebenslange freiheitsstrafe und
sicherungsverwahrung für marcus h acht
jahre haft januar vor ein paar tagen
ernst verteidiger plädiert auf totschlag
markus haas anwälte wollen freispruch
und heute dann mit spannung erwartet die
urteile anderthalb jahre nach dem tod
des regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
dauern bis es zur urteilsverkündung
kommt dann sprechen wir natürlich auch
direkt dazu zunächst aber geht es bei
stefan ernst ja auch eben um die frage
wie gerade im beitrag gehört mord oder
totschlag jetzt wird nicht jeder
zuschauer wissen was der unterschied ist
warum ist das wichtig und was ist er
also häufig wird in der öffentlichkeit
ja angenommen der unterschied zwischen
mord und totschlag sei dass der mord
vorsätzlich begangen wird und der
totschlag fahrlässig das ist aber nicht
der fall weil in beiden fällen wird
vorsätzlich ein mensch getötet und der
unterschied zwischen mord und totschlag
ist sehr dass beim mord zusätzlich noch
bestimmte merkmale hinzu kommen müssen
das sind die sogenannten mord merkmale
es gibt relativ viele davon hier im
konkreten fall sind zwei dieser merkmale
angeklagt nämlich zum einen die
heimtücke heimtücke bedeutet dass das
opfer dieses mordes m a close und auch
infolge dieser art losigkeit wehrlos war
im fall von lüpke ist das umstritten ob
das der fall ist denn weiter lücke so
sind jedenfalls die aussagen von stefan
ernst habe auf der terrasse durchaus
noch wahrgenommen dass er mit einer mit
einer waffe mit einem revolver bedroht
wird und in diesem fall war er zwei
velos aber nicht mehr ratlos deshalb
ja es wird mit spannung erwartet wie das
gericht diesen punkt sieht 1 weitere ein
zweites merkmal das angeklagt es sind
die sogenannten niederen beweggründe
hier hat die verteidigung von stefan
ernst gesagt dass keine niederen
beweggründe vorliegen würden
denn stefan ernst habe irrtümlich
geglaubt er handle im interesse der
allgemeinheit als der lübke erschoss
weil weiter lücke sich für die
flüchtlingspolitik der bundesregierung
eingesetzt habe und damit islamistische
anschläge begünstigt habe so
argumentiert die verteidigung von stefan
ernst hier auch hier muss das gericht
entscheiden ob niedrige beweggründe
vorliegen und man könnte durchaus
vertreten dass wenn man ein politiker
aus politischen gründen aus
rechtsextremen gründen erschießt dass
das niedrige beweggründe sind außerdem
wird stefan ernst das darf man auch
nicht vergessen noch versuchter mord an
einem irakischen flüchtlingen
vorgeworfen der im januar 2016 bei einem
messerangriff schwer verletzt wurde und
welche rolle spielt das jetzt in diesem
verfahren das spielt für die eigentliche
strafe spielt das nur eine
untergeordnete rolle weil sollte stefan
ernst wegen mordes verurteilt werden an
walter lübke
dann wird eine lebenslange haftstrafe
erhalten
und dann spielt es eigentlich keine
rolle ob er auch wegen versuchten mordes
an diesen geflüchteten noch verurteilt
wird
es spielt aber für einen anderen aspekt
eine wichtige rolle und zwar für die
sogenannte sicherungsverwahrung die
sicherungsverwahrung setzt nicht an der
schuld des täters an sondern die
sicherungsverwahrung geht von der
gefährlichkeit aus also wenn der täter
einen hang zu schweren straftaten hat
dann kann er eben auch über die
verhängte haftstrafe hinaus in haft
bleiben damit die allgemeinheit damit
die gesellschaft geschützt wird vor den
hut vor den möglichen taten dieses
täters und eine solche
sicherungsverwahrung kann man nur dann
verhängen als gericht wenn es mehrere
schwere straftat mehrere schwere
straftaten gegeben hat das heißt wenn
stefan ernst jetzt nur wegen mordes an
walter lübke verurteilt werden sollte
dann wird das gericht sich sehr schwer
damit tun
eine sicherungsverwahrung zu verhängen
deshalb spielt diese frage ob er auch
wegen versuchten mordes verurteilt wird
spielt in diesem zusammenhang eine rolle
wir sprechen gleich mit andreas hall
stand eine frage noch an dich christian
günther bentele facebook schreibt und
hallo herr decker wie gut ist eigentlich
die umgebung am gericht abgesichert ist
seeverkehr im hintergrund gibt es keine
sicherheitsbedenken
also der ganze prozess ist vom ersten
tag an stark abgesichert gewesen es gibt
eine hohe polizeipräsenz hier
das ist auch heute am tag der
urteilsverkündung so und der
gerichtssaal selbst das gebäude selbst
und dass es nur sehr schwer überhaupt
rein zu kommen
es gibt eine sehr limitierte platzzahl
die wegen corona noch mal deutlicher
limitiert ist und man darf in den
gerichtssaal als journalist als
journalistin und auch als zuschauerin
nichts mit rein nehmen außer einem block
und einen stift also man muss
mobiltelefon und alles was man bei sich
trägt abgeben dass es wie am flughafen
gibt es eine kontrolle nach
einlasskontrolle
das heißt die sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind
schon sehr hoch christian vielen dank
wir erwarten in jedem minuten sozusagen
die ersten auszüge aus dem mutter
beziehungsweise die ersten schritte zur
begründung die uns dann von dir gleich
präsentiert werden wir kommen dann zu
dir zurück sprechen jetzt aber erstmal
mit andreas hollstein denn man muss
sagen so schockierend
die tat an walter lücke ist es ist
leider kein einzelfall dass politiker
für ihre überzeugungen und auch für ihr
politisches handeln körperlich
angegangen werden also ja voll stein
ehemaliger bürgermeister der stadt
altena im sauerland altena ist es ebenso
ergangen schön dass sie bei uns sind
herr hall steigt schon morgen sie hören
nicht und ich höre sie auch gut dass es
schon mal prima auch sie haben sich ja
in ihrem heimatort für die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen eingesetzten hätten das
eben beinahe mit ihrem leben bezahlt das
war ein überfall auf sie in einem imbiss
bei dem ihn zum glück dann aber gleich
leute zu hilfe gekommen sind und der
täter auch überwältigt werden konnte
trotzdem ein furchtbares erlebnis kann
ich mir vorstellen wie oft denken sie
heute noch daran zurück noch alle die
wenig es kommt natürlich immer wieder
hoch
konfrontiert ist mit viel schwerer und
straff vertrag hatten wir zum glück oder
wenn man wieder hört dass eine kollegin
oder ein kollege nicht mehr antritt weil
er hass und bedrohung ausgesetzt ist ja
auch in ihrem fall hat der täter
ausländerfeindliche parolen skandiert
der konnte dann später aber in seinem
prozess keinem netzwerk so zugeordnet
werden hat dann eine bewährungsstrafe
bekommen damit mit einer
bewährungsstrafe ist heute natürlich
nicht zu rechnen im fall lübke mit
welchen gefühlen haben sie diesen
prozess verfolgt ja also natürlich mit
mit schon seit der tat mit sehr viel
nähe zu familie lücke die ich nicht
kenne
aber man kann sich natürlich auch
familiär da rein versetzen dass da
passiert wenn ein mensch ein politisches
amt ausübt in bestem wissen und gewissen
handelt humanität nach vorne stellt und
dafür dann nicht nur wie beispielsweise
in brega die oberbürgermeisterin von
köln die schwerverletzte wurde mit einem
messer oder bei mir eine leichtere tat
im feld das zu den breiten natürlich
oder wenn kollegen radmuttern gelöst
werden oder sie kugeln in den
postfächern finden wo sie sonst briefe
unternehmen das sind alles vollkommen
ist die dürfen nicht sein natürlich
nicht anders mit und natürlich kann man
sich ganz gut reinversetzen und mit uns
diese familie unendlich leid
ja auch wenn die täter natürlich nicht
identisch sind und auch die motivlagen
vielleicht nicht die gleichen aber wie
ist es wie haben sie das für sich
gemacht wie haben sie sich diese gewalt
erklärt ist es eine überforderung der
menschen es ist die unfähigkeit sich
irgendwie anders einzubringen sich gehör
zu verschaffen wie erklären sie sich das
naja wir sehen solche taten natürlich
nicht nur in deutschland sondern vor
wenigen wochen haben wir staunend vor
den vorgängen in washington vor dem
bildschirm gesessen und gesehen was da
passiert ich glaube dass die in teilen
der gesellschaft hemmungsloser wird und
andere menschen nicht mehr respektiert
und das ist glaube ich ein problem dem
wir uns stellen müssen und was auch gar
nicht nur mit dem
der frage von flüchtlingen und einsatz
für geflüchtete zusammenhängt sondern es
geht auch bei der aufstellung von
windrädern kommunal schon so weit dass
man beleidigt wird oder dass der haupt
drohungen ausgestoßen werden das ist ein
allgemein steigendes problem in der
bundesrepublik deutschland und die
müssen wir uns stellen und wir müssen
natürlich versuchen dass wir wieder
grund reinbekommen dieser dieser
messerangriff auf sie in dem imbiss
inwieweit der sich auf ihre politische
arbeit ausgewirkt sind sie seitdem
vorsichtiger geworden
nein eigentlich eigentlich gar nicht und
ich glaube wenn das so wäre hätte ich
steht es im jahr 2018
nach drei hörstürzen die ich gehabt habe
das war sicherlich noch die psychische
bewältigung dieses problems was
unterbewusst ablief hätte ich dann
zurücktreten müssen oder bei der
nächsten wahl nicht antreten müssen ich
habe wie in nordrhein westfalen
wahrscheinlich bekannt ist in dortmund
sogar kann kandidiert in der größeren
stadt im im september war da knapp nicht
erfolgreich aber das heißt ich kann auch
menschen weiter zu gehen ich kann mit
menschen weiter umgehen aber das muss
jeder für sich entscheiden der
fraktionsvorsitzende von bocholt in
nordrhein-westfalen hat nach hass mails
um drogen seinen rücktritt erklärt und
es gibt auch andere kommunale
mandatsträgerinnen und träger die
anschließend zu ihre mandate nicht mehr
ausüben wollten und konnten
olaf abhold schreibt uns über facebook
mehr schutz für kommunalpolitiker ist
nötig würden sie dem zustimmen und ist
das überhaupt machbar es gibt ja
unheimlich viele ja ich wir reden über
14.000 bürgermeister und es geht mir vor
allen dingen darum dass man nicht noch
von den bürgermeisterinnen und
bürgermeistern sprechen sondern wir
haben auch mitarbeiter in den rathäusern
die respektlos behandelt werden
im bereich der sozialen bereich der
ordnungsämter im bereich der feuerwehr
und der rettungsdienste und das ist ein
allgemeines thema und das kann man nicht
beantworten mit schutz für wenige und
ich glaube auch mein selbstverständnis
als kommunalpolitiker ist ich muss
menschen frei begegnen können ich kann
ich quasi ein bodyguard dabei haben
selbst völlig den
dabei haben können würde also ich habe
auch damals mich dann gleich wieder
normal in die arbeit gestürzt dass
fußball auch es ist sicherlich nicht
nicht einfach aber es ist nicht so
einfach zu sagen mehr schutz mehr
polizei mehr sicherheitskräfte seien
wir müssen als gesellschaft damit
umgehen ich glaube dass die gesellschaft
der beste schutz ist wenn klar ist dass
vorgänge im kleinen nicht in ordnung
sind aber erst recht nicht bei solchen
massiven angriffen auf unserer unserem
staat wie im fall walter lübke dann
können wir alle zeigt dass wir auf der
richtigen seite stehen das im besten
schutz
sie sind für ihre politik für ihr
engagement ausgezeichnet worden unter
anderem auch von der bundeskanzlerin
allerdings nie haben es für ihn auch
schon angesprochen sind auch sie eben
schon mit morddrohungen dann auch belegt
worden
wie versuchen sie das im alltag für sich
zu behandeln kann man das wirklich immer
so wegschieben oder kommt das dann nicht
doch in gewissen momenten immer mal
wieder vor das geistige auge und hat man
da nicht doch angst um sich und seine
familie vielleicht ja natürlich bleiben
der rest ängste und die sind häufig gar
nicht für die für die im blickpunkt
stehenden mandatsträgerinnen und
mandatsträger so entscheidend sondern
vor allen dingen für deren familien
also ich kann mich schon daran entzünden
dass im november 17 als der anschlag auf
mich war das dann der objektschutz
beispielsweise hochgefahren wurde das
heißt die polizei immer mal wieder vor
seinem privathaus stand das war kein
schönes gefühl und das macht auch
unsicher und das nimmt natürlich familie
liebende menschen in jeder fahrer mit
und das müssen wir auch dagegen kämpfen
dass solche vorkommnisse nicht sagen
können man kann politisch mit harten
bandagen kämpfen man kann auch mal
verbal durchaus scharf darstellen aber
man muss die integrität des anderen
spätestens da respektieren und vor
drohungen und was sollte man sich hüten
würden sie denn sagen dass sie ihre
politischen entscheidungen das war ja
alles in folge sozusagen der flüchtlings
thematik 2015 das attentat auf sie über
die entscheidung wieder so treffen
würden es ging ja darum dass ihre stadt
altena damals mehr flüchtlinge
aufgenommen hat als es nach dem
verteiler schlüssel sozusagen für
kommunen hätte aufnehmen müssen sie
galten als absolut großzügig und das hat
ihnen auch viel lob aber eben auch
scharfe kritik eingebracht würden sie
die entscheidung trotzdem wieder zu
treffen
nein erstmal ist wichtig festzuhalten
dass ich das nie alleine war sondern das
was alle politischen kräfte im rat der
stadt altena waren
wir hatten damals die ressourcen das
heißt werden sehr viele freiwillige die
sich gekümmert haben wir hatten eine
dezentrale unterbringung wir waren
sicher dass wir damit einen kleinen
beitrag leisten können um die not klar
zu machen und die hoffnung war damals
dass ich da mehr städte anschließen und
das so ein dominoeffekt sich entwickelt
aber das hat sich nicht entwickelt aber
trotzdem würde ich alles wieder genauso
machen weil ich glaube wenn politik und
die menschen die es gut mit unserer
gesellschaft meinen und das geht über
alle parteien hinweg wenn die aufhören
für einen besseren und guten start zu
kämpfen
dann können wir einpacken dann haben hat
unser staat ganz viel qualität verloren
und dafür kämpfe ich darf ist das war
der grund warum ich mal in die politik
gegangen bin und ich kann mich an die
gründe auch wenn ich mitten in den
wänden etwas älter geworden bin noch gut
erinnern er holte dann ich spreche gerne
gleich weiter mit ihnen wollen aber noch
mal ganz kurz zu christian decker
schalten denn es gibt das urteil
zumindest was das urteil ist das wollen
wir uns gerne jetzt nochmal direkt von
ihm abholen bitte ja das
oberlandesgericht frankfurt hat das
urteil gerade verkündet und stefan ernst
die höchststrafe verurteilt das heißt
lebenslange lebenslange haft und das
gericht hat auch die besondere schwere
der schuld festgestellt weil stefan
ernst das bedeutet dass nicht wie in
anderen fällen bei der lebenslangen haft
nach ungefähr 15 jahren zum ersten mal
der antrag gestellt werden kann dass man
auf bewährung freigelassen wird sondern
wenn die besondere schwere der schuld
festgestellt wird wird eine
mindeststrafe von einem
vollstreckungsgericht angeordnet und
erst nach ablauf dieser mindeststrafe
kann der verurteilte
erst einmal beantragen wieder auf freien
fuß zu kommen
das sind also deutlich mehr als 15 jahre
das können auch über 20 jahre sein denn
man kann also sagen dass stefan es in
jedem fall keine lange zeit ins
gefängnis muss man muss aber auch
gleichzeitig sagen dass dieses urteil
noch nicht rechtskräftig
rechtskräftig ist also alle beteiligten
können revision dagegen einlegen beim
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe
soweit also das urteil zu stefan ernst
zu markus haase ich gerade ist eine
bewährungsstrafe verhängt worden aber
dazu sprechen wir dann gleich du hast
jetzt mal ein paar minuten sich zu
sortieren christian vielen dank für
diese informationen einstweilen und
damit gehen wir noch mal zurück zur
andreas hollstein der das natürlich auch
mitbekommen hat dieses urteil jetzt im
fall lücke wie groß ist ihre
erleichterung ja sehr groß weil ich
glaube was anderes wäre familie nicht zu
vermitteln gewesen
ich hoffe dass die familie lücke auch
immer der straff markt spürt wie diese
gesellschaft und auch wie richter die
für diese gesellschaft handeln
dahinter stehen natürlich mussten musste
das ausgelegt werden aber wir haben ja
im vorfeld schon gehört dass das die
mordmerkmale zumindest einem urteil
umfrage waren und ich bin sehr froh dass
sie so entschieden beantwortet worden
ist weil das schreckt auch vor weiteren
taten ab wir haben in diesem staat bei
politischen straftaten gegen amtsträger
gegen amtsträgerin viel zu lange immer
noch die mentalität die mich in der
juristischen ausbildung begleitet hat
wir gucken mal auf welt auf den stoff
den täter im auge gehabt und wir müssen
hier meines erachtens viel stärker auf
generalprävention und deren elemente
gucken denn wenn da lasse urteile
gefällt werden der strafraum nicht
ausgeschöpft wird der jeweils da ist
dann führt das dazu dass menschen
ermutigt werden dem nachzueifern weil
das ist ja nicht so schlimm wenn man
alle politikerinnen oder 103 ja deswegen
noch mal der klare ausspruch eben von
ihnen auch dass sie sich erleichtert
zeigen über das verhängte urteil in dem
fall nämlich die höchststrafe er sie
hatten es gerade schon angedeutet geht
damit für sie auch eine signalwirkung
aus eben also nicht nur in bezug auf die
familie
sondern eben auch und ich glaube das hat
man sie für den auch schon anklingen
lassen sondern auch für den politischen
betrieb insgesamt dass man also nicht
schutzlos ist das ist eine ein
strafsystem gibt was eben auch mit
harten antworten reagiert auf solche
schrecklichen tat nicht ja ich glaube
dass das menschen die für unseren staat
agieren ob das mitarbeiter in verwaltung
oder mitarbeiter im feuerwehrtechnischen
dienst sind oder rettungssanitäter
bürgermeisterin und bürger heißt
ratsmitglieder auch einen schutz
brauchen und diesen schutz den gegen
unsere gesetze sie müssten nur
konsequent angewandt werden und das gilt
natürlich erst recht weil so eine
schlimme und verwerflichen tat wie wir
erlebt haben am zweiten juni 2009 10
aber das gilt auch für hass und hetze
das gilt auch für morddrohungen die
kollegen und kolleginnen heute noch
täglich irgendwo erreichen wir haben
nach einer umfrage von der zeitschrift
kommunal im jahr 2009 10 fast 60 prozent
der mandatsträger gehabt die ich schon
beleidigt oder mit hass und drohungen
überzogen worden sind und das darf nicht
so sein und das ist auch ein grund warum
ich stellung nehmen weil ich glaube das
sind wir uns einander schuldig wir
wollen dieses dieses land nach vorne
bringen egal mit welchem politischen
hintergrund und das wollte walter lücke
auch und deshalb bin ich einerseits sehr
traurig weil die die erinnerungen an
diese schreckliche tat wieder hochkommen
auf der anderen seite stelle ich fest
der staat ist noch handlungsfähig sie
sind selbst jurist wir wollen jetzt
nicht zu sehr in die details gehen aber
es ging ja unter anderem eben auch um
die frage ob mord merkmale vorliegen zum
beispiel eben auch die niedrigen
beweggründe und da hatte die
verteidigung von stefan ernst gesagt
nein das sei nicht der fall denn er habe
ja vermeintlich zum wohle des deutschen
volkes oder wie auch immer er sich da
ausgedrückt hat gehandelt solche
argumentationen müssen ihnen ja auch
befremdlich vorkommen
und ja ich finde die argumentation
bisschen herbeigeholt zumal unter den
niedrigen beweggründe ich bin es keine
strafe
rechtsexperte und liegt bei mir auch ein
paar jahrzehnte zurück auch rassismus
ein niedriger bewegen kann und diese tat
wurde mehr von rassismus geprägt als von
von von irgendwelchen rettungsaktionen
und jeder der behauptet dass irgendetwas
dem staate dient kann nicht in einer
demokratie für den staat sprechen
sonst müssten wir auch so weit gehen und
sagen dann haben die menschen die das
capitol gestürmt haben ja aus ihrer
sicht rechtfertigungsgrund nein den gibt
es nicht
rassismus ist widerwärtig hat in unserer
gesellschaft nichts zu tun und wenn
jemand aus rassismus eine solche tat
behandelt kann sie als niedriger
beweggrund eingestuft werden und ich bin
froh dass das gericht das so bewertet
hat bevor wir gleich noch mal mit
unseren kollegen vor ort sprechen
ich würde gerne noch wissen aus ihrer
erfahrung als kommunalpolitiker haben
sie ja eben auch öfter schon kontakt
gehabt mit sehr offenbar aufgebrachten
menschen nicht nur bei dem angriff auf
sie aber auch mit leuten mit
extremistischen einstellungen haben sie
das gefühl da gibt es oft noch die
chance die zurückzuholen in die
gesellschaft oder geben sie dann doch
auch einen gewissen prozentsatz von
menschen quasi verloren für gespräche
die irgendwie konstruktiv sind
man muss versuchen mit mit allen
menschen die friedlich sich mit einem
unterhalten wollen und können auch den
dialog zu führen auch wenn sie abstruse
ansichten haben muss eine gesellschaft
das interesse haben diese menschen in
ihren reihen zu halten und sie nicht
außerhalb stehen zu lassen
aber ich bezweifle dass das bei einem
teil der menschen die am rechten rand
aktiv sind und das gedankengut
verbreiten dass das dann auch möglich
ist also die funktionäre am rechten rand
werden wir nicht mehr kriegen die
hardliner werden wir nicht wegkriegen zu
denen ja auch der täter wohl gehörte und
auch der derjenige der beihilfe
geleistet hat
aber die menschen die davon verblendet
hinterherlaufen müssen versuchen für die
politik zurückholen zu politik kann sich
für menschen einsetzt und das muss sie
deutlich macht auch in dem sie immer
wieder den gesprächsfaden aufnimmt herr
holstein ganz lieben dank für diese
ausführungen das war sehr eindrucksvoll
mit ihnen zu sprechen über diese
thematik alles gute für sie und schön
dass sie bei uns in der sendung an
dankeschön
herzlichen dank und damit geht es noch
mal zurück zu christian decker also wir
haben vorhin ja von ihr schon gehört wie
die urteile waren beziehungsweise 1
konnte ich dann noch ergänzen vielleicht
fast es noch mal kurz zusammen also
stefan ernst wurde zur höchststrafe
wegen mordes hat also zu lebenslanger
haft verurteilt es ist das gericht hat
auch die besondere schwere der schuld
festgestellt von stefan ernst das heißt
er kann erst nach einer relativ langen
zeit auch sehr haft entlassen werden was
den versuchten mord an geht an dieser
stelle wurde stefan ernst freigesprochen
und das bedeutet dass die
sicherungsverwahrung nicht einfach so
verhängt werden konnte sondern das
gericht hat die sicherungsverwahrung
vorbehalten das heißt zu einem zelt oder
späteren zeitpunkt kann die
sicherungsverwahrung noch verhängt
werden was den mitangeklagten markus
hahn geht dieser wurde freigesprochen
vom vorwurf der beihilfe zum mord er
wurde aber wegen eines waffendelikts
verurteilt zu einer haftstrafe von einem
jahr und sechs monaten
und diese haftstrafe wird allerdings mit
der u haft die er abgesessen hat
verrechnet die verteidigung von markus
haar hatte gefordert dass er für die
eltern haft entschädigt werden muss und
diesen anspruch hat das gericht
abgelehnt das heißt es gibt keine
haftentschädigung für den mitangeklagten
markus haben das gericht hat
gleichzeitig aber auch klar gestellt
dass dieser freispruch von der ist von
der beihilfe zum mord nicht unbedingt
bedeuten muss dass er unschuldig war
haben sondern es gebe eben nicht
genügend beweise die für seine schuld
sprechen der vorsitzende richter sagte
dass es ebenso sei dass stefan ernst als
hauptbelastungszeuge
kein unabhängiger zeuge sei stefan ernst
habe in seinen geständnissen durchaus
auch lügen dürfen deshalb auch das trage
eben zum freispruch von markus habe ist
das trotzdem will die familie von walter
lücke eine ganz schwere us schwer zu
verdauen danach richten
die hatte ja als nebenklägerin
aufgetreten gefordert dass markus als
mittäter bestraft wird also nicht nur
als jemand der beihilfe geleistet hat
sondern der auch an der tat wirklich
direkt beteiligt war
in jetzt kommt das urteil so zustande
das muss doch eben schwer verdauen hatte
information
die familie hatte tatsächlich gefordert
dass auch markus h eine lebenslange haft
mit anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
mit entscheidung mit der feststellung
der besonderen schwere der schuld
erhalten soll
weil sie davon überzeugt waren dass
markus h und stefan ernst eben
gemeinschaftlich zusammen diesen mord
begangen haben
für die familie ist dieser freispruch
vermutlich schwer schwer hinzunehmen
weil sie sich weil sie eine andere
vorstellung von der tat haben weil sie
davon überzeugt sind dass markus h eine
viele gewichtige rolle gespielt hat dass
er eben mittäter war und der vor ort war
deshalb muss man jetzt sehen wieder die
familie nach der urteilsverkündung
darauf reagieren wird
das gericht hat im vorhinein gesagt dass
diese urteilsverkündung ungefähr zwei
bis drei stunden lang dauern wird
das heißt dass wird der verlauf des
tages noch zeit wir haben auch immer mal
wieder fragen natürlich hier von unseren
usern der real homer simpson auf youtube
die revision wird kaum etwas bringen
oder was erwartet sich die verteidigung
davon
also bei einer revision ist es so dass
der bundesgerichtshof nicht das
komplette urteil überprüft es wird also
zum beispiel keine neue beweisaufnahme
gemacht es wird nicht noch mal geprüft
stimmen die aussagen die stefan ernst
hier in seinen geständnissen gemacht hat
oder nicht sondern in einer revision
prüft der bundesgerichtshof
ausschließlich ob rechtliche fehler
gemacht wurden
also ob zum beispiel die bewegungen des
gerichts richtig vonstatten gegangen ist
und ob die rechtlichen schlüsse die das
gericht hier in seinem urteil heute
gemacht hat ob die vertretbar sind
das heißt das es wird nicht das ganze
urteil noch einmal überprüft sondern es
wird nur die rechtliche seite war von
überprüft man muss jetzt abwarten das
können theoretisch alle beteiligten in
diesem prozess können revision einlegen
innerhalb einer gewissen frist und man
muss jetzt einmal abwarten was die
beteiligten heute ankündigen oder auch
in den nächsten tagen
ich würde dich gerne noch kurz
konfrontieren mit einer weiteren frage
von nachts auf youtube gab es außerdem
einen komplizen noch andere verdächtige
mit dem sich das gericht beschäftigt hat
stichwort rechtes netzwerk
ja das ist eine frage die die ganze zeit
über diesen prozess hin
es ist so dass das es ja durchaus
hinweise gibt
das ist möglicherweise ein netzwerk oder
das ist noch andere beteiligte personen
gegeben haben könnte
das war aber in diesem prozess nicht ein
bestandteil der eine wichtige rolle
gespielt hat denn die bundesanwaltschaft
hat sich entschieden eben diese beiden
personen stefan ernst und markus h
anzuklagen
und in diesem strafprozess geht es nur
um die persönliche schuld dieser beiden
personen
deshalb hat das gericht was die umgebung
angeht nicht viel ermittelt und es ist
aber so dass es im hessischen landtag
einen untersuchungsausschuss gibt der
vor einiger zeit schon die die arbeit
aufgenommen hat dieser
untersuchungsausschuss hat letzte woche
zwei lkws voll gerichtsakten bekommen
das heißt die ganzen akten die in diesem
strafprozess hier eine rolle gespielt
haben und dieser untersuchungsausschuss
im hessischen landtag hat sich zur
aufgabe gesetzt
genau diese frage zu klären gab es
vielleicht noch weitere beteiligte leute
im hintergrund und auch was die
ermittlungsbehörden angeht also wurde
von seiten des verfassungsschutzes und
von seiten der ermittlungsbehörden
möglicherweise da nicht alles gesehen
vielleicht um eine ganz praktische
organisatorische frage auf wie geht das
jetzt heute weiter also die
urteilsverkündung dauert noch anders
dauert in der regel auch ein bisschen
länger als jetzt die paar minuten seit
10 uhr
die ist ja jetzt das weitere prozedere
heute im laufe des tages und was
passiert dann auch mit den beiden
angeklagten also die urteilsverkündung
wird sicherlich noch der ganze weile
dauern zwei bis drei stunden sind
angekündigt und stefan ernst wird in
jedem fall in haft bleiben davon dass er
sich herauszugehen
markus harder im oktober 2020 ja bereits
aus der u haft entlassen wurde wird
aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach auch hier
diesen gerichtssaal erst mal als freier
mann verlassen und die beteiligten also
die rechtsanwältin rechtsanwälte werden
sich sicher dann in ruhe das urteil
angucken und werden dann überlegen ob
sie revision einlegen oder ob sie dieses
urteil akzeptieren wollen ich gucke
gerade christian ob er noch fragen haben
von unseren häusern das ist aber zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt jetzt nicht mehr
der fall christian ich danke dir ganz
herzlich für diese berichterstattung vom
oberlandesgericht in frankfurt wir
fassen noch einmal kurz zusammen also
die höchststrafe für den
hauptangeklagten fischer vergeben
lebenslang und daneben die behrenstraße
ich vor dem hit angeklagte markus haben
bei vielen dank für diese informationen
und einschätzungen und euch natürlich
auch vielen dank fürs mitmachen und
fürst zu sehen
wir wünschen euch noch einen schönen tag
und sagen bis zum nächsten
leistungsschau